that's a bad thing
[Music]
oh man I forgot to go pee before we
started now we get to set up a this game
is barons better what's up Xavier a hi
hi hello everyone
Wow everyone's showing up quick showing
up all right quick I have hyper
spider-man ps4 Oh reconnections
successful you know what that does to
you alright hang on we're back maybe
possibly there we go that thing gets
control check it son this looks better
than anything I will ever do in this
game
this this is all gameplay I know I love
that these animations are all like just
game playing I mean like this is not a
cutscene at all is it is it bad I the
same that you do so
oh boy it's over okay hold on maybe go
try and see if there's other people in
the house using the internet and tell
them to maybe stop streaming nine things
of Netflix all at once sister yes okay
will she listen no but asking my sister
will die
it is it was it better is it connected I
can't tell who's he back oof huh oh yeah
don't worry guys this is always the kind
of thing I William hi I keep seeing you
screaming Xavier at the top of your
lungs but in text form one second
Brandon entertain everyone while I leave
oh [ __ ] yeah be entertaining okay okay
so you do some stand-up I can't even see
the [ __ ] text yeah he's alive still
Xavier mr. stark I don't feel so good
I don't feel so good spider-man ps4 II
random give me a [ __ ] hey what's up
let's say you respond to that
you gotta give an answer you can do it
baby boy oh god get off the stage
$50 holy [ __ ] Xavier Ford here I'm just
gonna just come here for a sec all right
you're mine he'll be surprised when it
comes back I bet we make $50 tops well
you've already broken that yep [ __ ]
Brandon's here yes I am physically in
the room $49.99 dollar donation from Lou
here let me read it it's it's from
Chidori 1 oh that guy and it says ah
take my money you beautiful human oh
that guy's great he's always sending big
donations I love you see Odori whoa
Hayden we'll try our best oh my
sit down we'll try to make we'll try to
make this [ __ ] funny for you okay it
hurts
is it working better now um let me check
but it seems to be continuous here yeah
alright now let's stream a whole bunch
of frames with spider-man you know sex
what there's certain ones that you
should read I was better about you sorry
yes okay oh yeah I just pressed like the
I pressed l1 and r1 to swing and I'm
like what the [ __ ] it but I've been
playing that I thought that would be the
right button alright I have not seen you
yet
this gameplay you'd be cooler if they
took the [ __ ] particle effects off so
that it doesn't look like shooting fist
lasers like a street fighter game and
stylized stylized stupidity
spider-man needs to hit people and it
looks like it hurts
he needs to hit people like Batman hits
people all of you read it can you hear
all three it was pretty low at the
microphone yeah that's a good way to
test the audio horrible edges
yes punch lasers spider-man's in a
naughty dog game yeah that it sounds
like everything's breaking the sound
barrier is it that's pretty we're like
you see him throw a punch but then you
hear it like several seconds later
Spidey seven says Brandon tell Xavier to
tell me
I spied seven staying out of trouble on
that discord server good good good for
you I'm proud of you excited I'm proud
of you son I'll ask for this new yield
agent how he's doing I feel really happy
about what I'm doing right now this is
the true spider-man shield loves blue
have AI think that Devine
I love how shields at uniforms are so
goddamn consistent they might as well be
x-men just put in the color blue maybe
the color white it's fine consistency's
for nerves I can't jump
got another 49 man what no same guy hey
please I love Chidori yeah that's pretty
good
you're the most amazing I love you I'm
gonna give you the biggest hug come to
Denver Comic Con so I can personally hug
you you're invited to his birthday party
you are in fact invited to my birthday
party I have invited a lot I've
uninvited a lot of people from it
especially David I've uninvited him a
couple dozen times just because I really
wanted to get the point across
well you chia Dori one thank you I love
him he's great I cancelled my birthday
party just so David couldn't go I just
want him to be there still tough I love
you David it was really nice to meet you
if you ever watch her and listen to this
David's probably gonna show up just for
a few seconds to yell and [ __ ] post in
the comments about how I'm not screaming
dead space where you were no help at
Ron's kept telling me I sound just like
this version of spider-man and I'm like
can you not the voice actors might
[ __ ] the police favorite part about
this game there is MJ he's got a [ __ ]
rating boys look like stormtroopers they
do don't they that's why I was so
concerned like they look I really don't
like Jesus Christ
okay we'll start asked when you're doing
your boxing match with them is that
still a thing I mean you know whenever
is free with you
I still got a faceoff with Emma's parka
and Marvel vs. Capcom and vibe or
whatever before her infinite I don't
care but he won't buy the game so I
bought the game for nothing
after he already said on Twitter that
he'd fight me in it well that guy just
came out like hey this isn't this is the
best this suit has looked in a game I
think the classic suit yeah yeah kind of
mad that we don't see the classic suit
if we haven't seen the classic suit in
games and like since this game well as
the starter suture well cuz in the edge
of time you see like the weird one with
that right right right
or you get the amazing spider-man movie
suits but those aren't quite like the
comic here Brandon do you want to play
sure I eat this cheeseburger and and
read questions
hey hey Mendoza's do a let's play well
it's more extreme than a let's play yeah
I know you just tried to do the the web
strike thing we don't have it unlocked
yeah no you have to let Luke Cage to
just hot-ass spider-man muscle muscle
memory kicked in immediately Yeah right
I did it to you Xavier eat healthy food
Mason I think there's bacon too but I'm
not sure how do you stick to walls again
the button is just push up against it
and hold it down for a little bit which
I don't like the fact that it keeps
knocking me off the wall is super
annoying yeah but if you actually just
don't do anything you'll just step back
to it hi dark net van 75 walk dude yeah
how do you think of the spider-man and
also videos I wish my video my videos
got as many views as spider-man and Elsa
that donation well funny thing about
that is that wait I'm kind of already
working on like - someone asked me to
help voice part of theirs and then also
if you guys remember the socially inept
spider-man sketches from my reviews the
animator from that actually wants me he
actually that's how him and I met if you
want Hugh an animated series where I
write it and voice it and we're kind of
working on that is just like a side
thing
this game hey Xavier how you been I know
Twitter can be held glad to see you
happy
Congrats on the court case win with your
girlfriend seriously I'm really happy
for you from rabid rocky oh yeah thank
you I appreciate that
heard about the new invincible animated
series no I didn't that's awesome what's
your favorite Spidey enemy oh I love
venom a lot he's rad it started just
like this for illegal fight or grow yeah
anyway um for people who don't know
because I've been very I've been talking
about a lot on the discord and the
Twitter but I don't know if it's been in
the videos um the past couple of months
have been a little rough because me and
my girlfriend have just been kind of she
stressed out about this port battle
thing going on because she had a stalker
who we were pressing charges against and
his lawyer was pulling some disgusting
tacit tactics
oh that's rad I love this job look it's
so cool anyway um yeah well anyway after
a long while and a lot of stress we
finally beat him and the guy got
sentenced to 10 years Fox on the run
away his comic version
I love the run away his comic I read it
like in preparation for the show and I
was really surprised how like unique and
cool and
and then whoa you got smacked through
like nine cars it's like it's an app
thing I think it's like this forever
okay
no says Xavier senpai notice any newbies
in chance hello I noticed you out there
say curse you Amy Pascal you want me to
say it like I did in the video like just
saying general
cursed you Amy Pascal oh I could I feel
like I could add better
why is Venom's first instinct when
fighting spider-man for a man coughs
well you listen to a lot of Ice Cube
that day it's where I like oh my god
where the cops are shot look at that in
that scary I love that
this shit's awesome why does he doing
the zombie
are you the bomb squad Xavier you could
direct one movie studio right side what
would it be I would like to make a dead
space
got a stop me from getting the MJ you
got to stop him
you're supposed to throw cars at it at
this party hey Xavier what I'm playing
with the punching punch man is from NWA
God in spider-man's from wu-tang and
that's why they're fighting anything
helps all of the donations are
appreciated me how big or small we let's
go we really love you guys thank you so
much for being so generous present size
doesn't matter size doesn't matter it's
how you use it so Josh just stares like
a naive for like three seconds
the game ended he gave me this really
weird stare when Brendan pulled some
[Music]
you're out swinging that swings his legs
to the left end to the president to the
back end then I'm freaking wet kind of
twitching a bit you know what I noticed
about this game is that for some reason
spider-man's been down a lot and looks
really weird doing see it's called
pointing your toes
I don't know like I understand when
you're pointing them off but pointing
them down don't point your toes up you
point them down it's like a gymnast and
a dancer thing you notice some of these
are actually animations from spider-man
3 yeah I [ __ ] love this one that's a
good one
the swinging animations and just the
swinging in general is so good insane
Hulk retrospective part 3 I'm probably
gonna take a break from the whole
retrospective for a little bit because
that third hole game is a [ __ ] thank
you leemaster you're my favorite person
in the comments today said I'm his
favorite you guys saw I was before you
could say friendly just kidding all and
you were my favorite a little bit gang
wound em boys well and that was people
that was shitty yes you can't oh yes you
can
yeah going on alright next person who
did keep you say I am the boss [ __ ]
it's homecoming better than spider-man 2
you know what because spider-man 2 has
good fight scenes for spider-man
actually for champions no books when
covering spider-man is just a kid I'm
gonna kick your ass
I wish Tom Holland would beat me up
while I wear a spider-man costume dude
that's so cool biggest ad of the Marvel
Universe's Luke Cage look how little I
give a [ __ ]
his clothes are tatters now no you
should be naked at this it's fine his
clothes have the same suit ours he yes
yeah his clothes are made of a metal
table model they just missed every shot
right he's got he's got a picture photo
shoot this is the same character model
of Luke Cage
yeah it is and isn't that kind of
[ __ ] here like you have the assets
you know they're like totally different
developers and studios it's not exactly
the same but it's the same outfit it's
really close and I don't think that's
like specifically a character like a
costume war
like it's just an interpretation of his
Cosmo he had he had just a yellow
t-shirt no I know that but like
specifically the cage belt buckle and
those shoes he has on I mean he's had
those before maybe not this specific
combination but it was weird man
I lost looking back at the shack as Luke
Cage now dude the rock is Luke Cage Oh
Aziz Ansari as Luke aid the shat dude
Shaq is a terrible actor oh he so is for
sure at least at least the rock wouldn't
provide some charisma right but Wow but
bill he's just a big dude those big rift
muscley dude all right
Shaq you gotta get big and rifted what's
your best okay Henry Cavill Bautista is
Luke Cage
I can't Josh what yo dude hope this
stream goes great I've missed you man oh
yeah I've been talking to him before
he's pretty cool he's a good r2 can an
eh $902 you decide about spider-man ps4
talk about that since or should we wait
for later in the stream when like we get
a little more viewers
let that go a little bit you can talk
about your feelings yeah okay we'll
build up to that we need you we need you
to express your feelings sometimes right
oh my god Xavier acknowledged my
existence twice in two days I was the
guy who left the comment all caps
freaking out the eyes chat it's so fast
you met comics explained on Instagram oh
yeah I met comics explained if you guys
heard of him I met him at comic-con he's
a sweet man he's actually really nice
you see I've I wasn't so sure yeah whoa
yeah you vitamin I've heard him much
never met him because I wasn't there on
that day oh yeah um yeah I don't know
like a couple times before I've
complained about his style of content
because I feel like people should read
comics instead of just having someone
else give them a summary of them you
know like I feel like comics are meant
to be appreciated and read because a lot
of people put a lot of work in drawing
and writing them and you know at least
you could do is though I was real all
I'm sorry sorry but the least you could
do is like read it you know but I
realized that a lot of the people who
rely on his videos as a crutch you know
it's not exactly his fault though
because there's a lot of fake fans or
just like I'll tell everyone I'll tell
everyone I'm a sniper huge comic fan but
I'll only watch that guy's videos and
maybe comics torreón that's not his
fault he's just doing videos that make
it easier to explain like reading orders
for people and you know he's a good guy
a rod King Xavier can you give me a
shout-out please no
trekker XD 75 quick question what are
your thoughts on Scottie young as their
Oh Scottie Young's Deadpool book I
actually read the first issue of it
oh boy I I don't know it wasn't terrible
but it felt it felt more like a 2010
Deadpool comic and I have yet to
determine if that's a good thing or not
I want to see where it goes
because it looks like they're trying to
reorient it to be as close to movie
Deadpool as possible and that's already
not a decision I'm really happy with I
was not down for the way they liked the
last Deadpool run and greed just injects
himself with a bunch of memory erasing
drugs oh yeah I was gonna say there was
a guy in the chat that said it at the
very beginning I'm sorry white wall run
again chat but he won't run again okay I
didn't play the tutorials and it's been
a long time
Xavier senpai notice me also if you
click God of War 4 so does name you're
not currently playing that together yeah
we haven't finished it yet though we're
like we barely just finished the all
time area shout out to Luke Cage having
to give spider-man out of this crime for
yeah I know what I'm doing man nah dude
spider-man isn't stop frame I was just
about to say something about it
shoutout to Luke Cage having to give
spider-man to death through speech oh
okay
I'm spider-man but I didn't think to do
that I was stopping crime before you
[ __ ] found me today thanks chat thank
you guys you know what spider Gatton
it's really funny that you just have we
just have a string to help construct
this right I wish I had that for these
kinds of games what else do i retros
what's this dream goes great leaf for
you Xavier huge fan good luck to your
channel hey thank you you know I'm sorry
everyone that I haven't been around I've
had life stuff going on it's it's a
combination of being stressed about
stuff in real life and then
being a little burnt out because I was
working on videos kind of non-stop for a
little while and that's not exactly
helping
boria is it it kind of it can both like
worry you down physically and
emotionally and also kind of kill your
wife to do it but like now that I've
taken like about a month off maybe a
little longer I actually kind of feel
like motivated to do it again because I
actually have like three or four ideas
for videos I want to work on I'm gonna
get on those soon wow you got a hit by
that that taxi at going like it's not
like sometimes now that's I love this
place
chat is giving you look I love you guys
they appreciate you and I appreciate you
ups I love you summarizing Oh someone
said no problem honey so one thing that
I did notice is that the webs don't
attach directly to the building they
don't actually make connection with the
buildings when you swing there for this
game is trash and honestly I really
think that they could have gotten a
little bit closer to the buildings it's
not too bad and I'm hoping that
Activision will fix this before the
release they release date so I asked how
old I am I am 19 sweet boy take it up I
have 19 Brandon is 8
I'm about to turn into you're about to
turn 19 josh is like seven he's like 34
in dog years
yeah I mean my god I'm just Toni fired
for it
yeah I'm still 19 my birthday is next
like that Xavier just had to make a
point about that age gap yeah yeah I'm
19
book my girlfriend's 25 yeah 19 okay all
right I have no shame
yeah I know it's actually I got a little
shame I have too little shame you need
more to shame you need more shame in my
life guys can we get more shame over
here hey can I get another artist game
over here yeah I'm gonna get a refill
we're gonna freakin shame I was drinking
change